Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab, the podcast.
And today we thought we would,
we would tell a lie, right?
That's we're looking at, we're going at,
we're going to, we're going to, yeah,
no, I think we should get on with it. Yes.
This one comes to us from an
producer, Lulu Miller. All right,
so I'm going to tell you a story.
[inaudible] takes place in Germany who
can talk at an old folks home. Hello.
That's not where we are right now, but,
and we brought two of the people who
work at the home flow into a studio.
We have to close the door. It sounds
like you're having a party over there.
So the story really belongs to this
guy. Richard knew right there. Yeah.
He's the director of the home,
which is called Ben Wrath
senior center in Philadelphia.
But we've also brought [inaudible] who
also works at the home and speaks more
English. I just held Mr
[inaudible] talked to today.
We do it like this. Yeah. Okay. So
Mr New right there has a problem.
John [inaudible], Lloyd as houseful.
It's a problem. Most nursing homes face.
I meant to mention this house, my lesson,
which is that many people
who develop dementia,
Alzheimer's, they'll become disoriented
and confused and suddenly think,
why am I am? Where am I?
This is not my world and I
have to go back to my house.
My children are waiting for
me. And usually you know,
nurses will intercept them.
Relax, you are living here.
But occasionally people somehow slip
out the front door. Yeah. Escapes.
They happen. And then they wander.
[inaudible] they had one woman make it
onto a bus and she escaped about how many
kilometers she eventually made it
to a town about 20 miles away. Yeah,
they've had people turn up at grocery
stores, wandering in the forest.
They've even had people make it all the
way back to their old houses and find
new people living there. Yup.
And for the people who work at the home
says regain Yo yo get crazy not knowing
ways
first. And then where did
she go? Test, test, test,
test. This is something
we all know about you.
Do you guys know I'm working on this
story about the Alzheimer's? Yes.
And while reporting this piece,
so I was checking in with my parents
about some stories like this.
What happened to my grandpa. Wow. Wow.
And they told me when I never heard
one morning, this was in February. Yes.
This was on a very, very
frigid cold morning.
My grandpa got up five in the morning,
left the house and walked
to the train station.
You probably got the earliest tea ticket
all the way up to Cambridge cause he
thought he had to teach a class at
Harvard. Did he used to teach at home? No,
but he'd given lectures there.
So anyway, that's my pitch.
Dark early in the morning,
frigid Boston weather and he was only
in his long underwear with his coat and
hat and scarf on over that
he didn't even have shoes on.
He was just wearing a slipper. He was
picked up by the police because he was,
you know, um, hypothermic.
Yeah, he was hypothermic.
He was hypothermic. I mean his,
when they brought him into the hospital
and his temperature was too low down to
none on that,
it was the moment when I
knew that, um, you know,
that everything was
going to have to change,
that he would have to move into a place
that had a floor for people who are set
for locked floor. That's what it meant.
So
essentially is the problem. Some
people have to to be locked in,
which just feels cruel.
Yeah. That's horrible. Yeah,
it is.
And then in walks of fellow
named Mr Google. No, no,
no. Good, bad. No. Good,
good. Really awful.
Oh really? Okay. Try to make
it more like Gerber goodbye.
Yeah. Okay. No good that.
Oh, okay. We'll just like, we'll
just use you saying it. We'll do it.
Your Mr. Mr. Good. Okay.
So Ms [inaudible] good.
It was an older gentleman.
He sat on an advisory board of the
senior center and one day he came up with
this idea. Yeah, that's
Richard. No, right there. Again,
I'm at Michelin and it's one of these
ideas that's so out there and yet so
simple that you think it
just couldn't possibly work.
When Mr Gerber came into the office
of the shot and presented his idea,
Chad was just laughing. Ally's come Altius
he thought it's very funny.
What a funny idea. Well,
what is it already? What's the idea? Well,
Mr Google thought that right in front
of the home they should build a bus.
Stop the bus stop. What? Build a bust. I,
I don't understand what,
what would that do? Well,
think about what a bus stop is.
When you see a bus stop. It's a,
the first step into the wide
world from the little bus stop,
you get a anywhere. Yeah.
Bergene says that in a lot
of these wandering cases,
the first place people often
head is to a bus stop. Ah,
and so back to our friend Mr Gerber,
he thought what they should do is build
a bus stop right in front of the home
that has just one crucially odd feature.
There's snow bus coming, no bus, never.
It's the best stuff to nowhere.
So his thought was moment,
it would be a way of catching
people who happened to wander. Okay.
They'd see the bus stop,
go and sit on it waiting for a
bus that would never come to.
And then eventually a staff member
could see them and bring them back.
No chief officer. So while Richard's
first thought was, this is ridiculous.
Second thought, hmm, maybe not that bad.
Right.
So they bolted in a bench, made off Iran,
put up the sign in yellow and green, just
like every government issued bus stop.
And when you get out of the
home, you see it immediately
[inaudible]
and the staff as I'm, or does she leave?
Say Richard and Regina just
thought this was a stupid idea. Oh,
it's not appropriate.
Or it's even cynical and most of all
that it probably just wouldn't work.
Yeah. And at first it
looked like they were right.
[inaudible] I've also one by
one, the neighbors, you know,
normal people, they said, oh, new bus.
And they waited there for the bus.
And so one by one Richard would have to
run out and explain this. Not for you.
That's fascinating. That sticked his
name. There was this period of adjustment.
Yeah, and then one day and now old lady,
an actual patient from the home.
He started having an episode.
She was very troubled in her mind.
She was a little girl and she
needed to get home to her parents.
My mother waits for me. I have
to go home. Her mom very quick.
The nurses talk to her
and try to calm her down,
but she began to cry
so they thought, well,
let's just let her walk out. It
was fall. It was brother cold,
so she went to the best of in her
coat and her head and she said,
they're very patient and
she waited for the bus
in the fresh air, Sun shining
and eventually a nurse came over and
sat with her and they weighted together
side by side.
Eventually she forgot why she was there.
The nurse said,
we go in and have a cup of tea together
and then she came back and everything
was fine. She was relaxed.
She was in the present time,
not longer. In the past time,
it's been two years since the bench
first went up and Richard and regain,
say they use it all the
time, every couple of days.
Sometimes the nurses will take someone
who's upset and wants to go home.
The nurses say, let's go to the bus stop,
let's see what we will do
and how we plan the day.
And or sometimes the nurses, they don't
see that somebody escaped and they say,
Oh way's Mrs. Smith. And then
they look out over the wall.
She's waiting for the boss.
Yeah, and somebody go out there.
But one thing is always the
same. When the people get to
the bus stop, the mood is very dark.
I'm feeling so lonely. I want
to go home and also urgent.
My parents wait from me, my children
wait for me. I have to go there quick,
quick, quick. But then
after awhile
as they're sitting there thinking
their escape is on the way,
that urgent feeling disappears.
Did, do you know why or can, I guess,
can you describe it disappearing?
Like does it go away
slowly or suddenly be,
forget the Denzel's
[inaudible] almost undersigned
where his start and
[inaudible].
It's like another thought comes up
and then you forget what you wanted.
Yeah, no,
it's like a fish is coming
up to as a surface of a water
going down again and disappearing
thoughts come up and they disappear.
You don't know that they have
ever been there. Oh yeah.
You'll forget which is, it's interesting.
It's the forgetting is both the
problem and the solution. Yeah.
The Lulu,
I mean isn't this maybe a little bit
cruel because it is a lie that's happening
here. I mean they are lying to these
people. Well, sure. It's definitely a lie.
There's no way around that, but
what's the alternative? I mean,
take that woman at the bus stop.
What are you supposed to say to her?
I know that you're
utterly convinced of this,
but actually you're not a little
girl. You live in a nursing home.
As you can imagine, these kinds of
conversations don't go well. No.
They say sometimes they have to
restrain the people, hold them back,
call the police. They don't accept
it because it's not their world.
It's two completely different
world. And so they say,
why not just allow that other world to
be true for just a beat and then gently
coax them back beds.
The aim of the whole thing to lead
those memories very gently into this.
Now this today and this idea has
sort of spread at the nursing home.
It changed the atmosphere in the home.
Now they try to do this sort of
time shifting in all different ways.
Sounds a little bit complicated,
but it isn't. Like for example,
they had this guy who's a baker who was
used to want to get up at two o'clock in
the morning and they used to say, no,
you know, go back, go back to bed. We're,
we're working. Yeah. But now they just
say, okay. And they let them get up
at two o'clock they take him the
kitchen and let him bake a van. He says,
well,
I'm always in time and I'm proud
I never miss an hour of mine.
And the interesting part for me is
that I think about my grandpa wandering
through the cold and his slippers,
and here's this way in which people can
be somewhat lost in their memories and
yet exist in the present, safely, safely
separate. It's
removing Miller with the music choice.
If you want to know anything more
about the Ben Rats senior center in
Dusseldorf, Germany, check
our website, radiolab.org
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.